looking toward the midterms the GOP is
bouncing back in states that Democrats
were all set to pick up it's time to
toast more beers for Brett baby we will
examine the Cavanaugh effect taking
place all over our country then Hillary
Clinton pontificates on how to treat
sexual assault accusers CNN puts on a
modern-day minstrel show and cocaine
myths turns the Pablo Escobar all the
way up to 11 Sebastien Gorka stops by to
discuss why we fight finally on this day
in history the phrase going postal
enters the American lexicon
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the Cavanaugh effect
hip hip hurray hip hooray oh how
delicious we have a lot more of that and
we're gonna I'm gonna need a refill on
this so if you could get Cory Booker on
the line where I'm gonna quickly we're
gonna make some money honey with an ad
but if you could get Cory Booker on the
line I'm gonna need a refill before we
get into the Cavanaugh effect on all the
mid term polls today let's thank our
wonderful sponsor over at ring you know
ring I talk about ring all the time ring
is super cool it is the Jetsons it's the
video doorbell that connects to your
cell phone they've totally changed the
home security game with this doorbell
it's you know the neighborhood watch is
like very 20th century this is a very
21st century so they send me these clips
every once in a while to see ring in
action it's great you know because you
can see the person who's coming to your
door you can talk to them you can scare
them away so in this one a crazy-looking
guy walks up to a home the first thing
you hear is him trying to kick down the
door doesn't work that well
and then the homeowner catches him hey
leave my house I'm calling the police
okay what you need to do hey there's my
house stop now or I'm calling the police
why would you tell me that because
you're trying to push my door in leave
now I'm calling the police
okay is really not nice to make fun of
that guy because he's missing a lot of
teeth and you know but I don't think
he's the police that's what I'm saying
is I don't think it is the police
right now you can save up to $150 on a
ring of security kit at ring.com slash
anoles KO wles
these things are super cool they're very
inexpensive for the quality and what you
get out of it ring.com slash no les
canaux wles
$150 off when you go to ring.com slash
knowles okay so we've been talking about
the Kavanaugh effect now for two weeks
meaning the well we've been doing about
the effect of Democrats on the Cavanaugh
confirmation which is shameful
disgraceful but now we're seeing the
Cavanaugh effect on the midterm
elections and this is hurting Democrats
in races across the country not just the
swing states but races that we were
pretty certain that we were gonna lose
are now looking like they might flip for
reaction we turn to Cory Spartacus
Booker I hurt where dick durbin called
me I had tears of rage when I heard
about this experience in that meeting
and for you not to feel that hurt and
that pain hmm Wow could we I'm sorry
could we just one more time before we
really get into the show here could you
could you tell me a senator Spartacus
what did you feel
I hurt where dick durbin called me I had
tears of rage when I heard about this
experience in that meeting and for you
not to feel that hurt and that pain mmm
very good thank you thank you very much
tears of rage that's what Democrats are
feeling all around the country here the
Cavanaugh effect is affecting a lot of
races so we've got Dean Heller in Nevada
that race is turning around martha
mcsalley right now in Arizona has a
six-point lead over her Democrat
opponent Kyrsten Sinema so this is the
race at you know with the Jib we thought
Arizona was probably going to flip with
John McCain dying with you know flake
stepping down and right now martha
mcsalley is leading there's also in that
race a Green Party candidate Angela
green that that coincidence is just too
much right she was she must have just
just probably like some random street
person she thought I know what I can do
I know how I can make some money for the
next two months
the Green Party Angela green so she
she's gonna play a role too she's gonna
pull some votes away from the Democrat
it seems why is that the case why aren't
the democrats united because they
overplayed their hand on Brett Kavanaugh
you know it's it's very easy to separate
people by race it's much harder to
separate people by gender because the
genders are constantly unified and
together we all have mothers many of us
have lives and girlfriends you know
women have fathers and sons and husbands
and boyfriends so it's it's much harder
if you overplay your hands if it if it
seems that you're being unfair
and you're assassinating the character
of a guy just for being a guy just
because you can that's a that's a real
problem so and we're seeing that you
know we're seeing this play out not just
in the Senate we're seeing it on
campuses as well we'll get to that a
little bit later Marsha Blackburn is up
18 points on Democrat Phil Bredesen in
Tennessee a little note of warning on
this this is according to the New York
Times that she's up 18 points I don't
really believe this before the race
showed her up just I think six points
according to even the most ambitious
polls right now they have polls in real
time and the New York Times you're
seeing members come in as they are
contacting people I don't know this is
obviously about the entertainment aspect
of Elections but I am a little skeptical
still 18 points is pretty pretty good so
even if she's really only up 8 points or
9 points or even 6 points pretty good
and and those numbers were not looking
that way before
in Texas remember we were told that beta
O'Rourke the robert Francis overworked
he goes by Beto or Beto
but he's is colloquially and known among
Republicans as beta beta O'Rourke is now
down to 44 points Cruz looks at he's up
at 53 I mean that's a that's a sizable
lead again it's it's still close he's
still within striking distance but those
numbers that gap really widened because
of Cavanaugh right now Nate Silver has
dropped his prediction that Democrats
will take the Senate down to nineteen
point four percent likelihood so that's
the this is an all-time low for this
midterm cycle really not looking good
now a word of caution I don't want
Republicans to get complacent the
Democrats according to silver have a 78%
chance of taking the house which you
know historically speaking they're
likely to take the house they probably
as a as a matter of trends they should
take the house but their chances to take
this at the Senate are much lower now
and then that brings us to North Dakota
this race is one of the most beautiful
ones Heidi Heitkamp ever since this
Cavanaugh thing has dragged on her
numbers have been falling and then she
finally decided she was gonna vote no on
Cavanaugh and you know Joe Manchin ended
up voting yes another swing state
Democrat a Democrat in a state that
voted for Trump Heidi Heitkamp said no
why because she's got a lot of pressure
on her
on the left money is gonna go away donor
donor money of course also foundations
organizations that are donating to her
that money will dry up those activists
will dry up those ground game supporters
will dry up if she voted for what she
thinks about you know if she voted for
what is just and also what probably
would be politically right in a general
election that would have all gone away
so look the Cavanaugh thing was exposed
as a total farce
and Heidi Heitkamp however now is trying
to have it both ways she was always
trying to have it both ways we'll talk
about politicians who try to have it
both ways now so she votes no on
Kavanagh
here's Heidi trying to explain this away
make sure I understand you listened to
his testimony yeah I listened to his
testimony and then I went back and
watched his testimony with the sound
turned off what does that do for you
because I think that there's so many
different ways that you communicate and
you learn a lot by doing that it's it's
a it's an it's an old trick that I use
to really try and understand what's
being communicated the old trick that I
try to you this is the old trick that I
so when reality doesn't agree with my
preconceived idea logical convenient
notions this is a little trick that I
use I take my two fingers and I plug
them into my ear and then I close my
eyes really tight and I make this out la
la la la I can't hear you a lot that's
the heidi heitkamp trick this is NE
worst excuse she could have possibly
come up with says you know you heard
Cavanaugh and you found his testimony
compelling right yes yo yeah totally
know what he said when he said what he
said then I believed it so Dan I did
this little trick I needed him I put I
muted him I listened with the sound off
okay this is something by the way so
sometimes at night sweet little ELISA
will will say to me I'll mention
something and I'll say you know I talked
about this on the show today she goes oh
Mack I listened to your show every day
on mute I everyday I've got to take it
up on my iTunes and I click the mute
button and I listened to the whole show
that's less heidi heitkamp talking about
brick avenue oh I listened to brick
Alvin all the time on you okay
really said it's the best that they've
got this this obviously is an emperor
has no clothes moment I mean she was
just totally caught with it the best she
could say is yeah well I listen to him
and he was compelling so then I forgot
and I tried to forget but also it you
know it shows the difference between
conviction politicians and convenience
politicians and this is an important
distinction because when you look
throughout history history has a
probably many more convenience
politicians than conviction ones but
history doesn't look kindly on
convenience politicians people who just
go with the wind don't stand for
anything at all just want people to like
them just want to grand eyes as to
self-aggrandizing
just look around the Second World War
you've got Lloyd George or Lloyd George
Neville Chamberlain you squishy wishy
wishy-washy people and then you've got
Winston Churchill who look Winston
Churchill had major election losses he
had major victories for civilization but
he was a conviction politician he knew
what he believed he knew what he
believed about the Soviet Union what he
believed about Hitler what he believed
about Nazi Germany all these other guys
wish he wish he never Chamberlain Lloyd
George history looks on them like total
cowards in modern parlance they'd be
called cucks
you know it's just nobody wants to be
that Addante
he puts the apathetic in in the first
first circle of hell when he when dante
goes into hell when he passes through
the gates of hell the first people he
encounters or the apathetic the people
the angels who didn't rebel against god
but they didn't defend god they just
were always in it for themselves they'd
kind of were a little wishy-washy they
didn't have any convictions those guys
he sometimes is misquoted you know
there's that quote all it takes for evil
to succeed is for good men to do nothing
and this is variously attributed to
Edmund Burke and and Dante and all of
these people none of whom said those
precise words but that's where it comes
from and Dante it's the first souls that
he encounters and they're damned mercy
doesn't want them justice doesn't want
them heaven doesn't want them hell
doesn't want them they're just not
they're just in it for themselves and
that is politicians like Heidi Heitkamp
there Jim it's so pathetic I mean nobody
why would you put yourself through this
why would you put yourself through the
grooc
awful experience of running for office
sitting in office going to all those
spaghetti dinners going to constituent
town halls what why would you do that if
it's for nothing other than yourself
what is the point of that
you know the convenience politician par
excellence is Bill Clinton he of course
he is the one he's back in the news now
as well but you know that Bill Clinton
actually had a basically good presidency
he had a lot of good things come out of
his presidency not in the first couple
years but only after Newt Gingrich and
the Republicans won the Congress and
Clinton went along with them but there
was there were many achievements of
welfare reform tax reform free trade
deals there were a lot of good things
that came out of the Clinton presidency
his wife is a little less so you know
his wife too goes along with the spirit
of the age you remember in 2008 she said
abortion should be safe legal and rare
then she came around and said abortion
you know should be a sacrament basically
she's running in 2016
and she just you know a safe legal and
rare never made any sense if abortion is
just some meaningless medical procedure
why should it be rare if it's tantamount
to murder why should it be illegal and
you know just trying to be Neely mouths
have their cake and eat it too
Bill Clinton would say this I think he
was asked about the Gulf War what he
would have done with regard to sending
in American troops in the Gulf War the
first Gulf War and he I I'm only
slightly misquoting him when he said
well I would have gone along with the
opinion of the majority but I would have
felt empathy with the feeling of the
minority uh I feel your pain I feel your
pain that's the that's his campaigner I
feel your pain and so now the Clintons
are back in the news because history
doesn't look kindly on those people who
stand for nothing and the the other
problem by the way with people who stand
for nothing is they can really become
radicalized Hillary more than her
husband had leftist convictions she
wrote her whole College thesis on Saul
Alinsky on rules for radicals she'd
loved the guy should write to him all
the time and the trouble is when the
spirit of the age moves far left moves
in a radical direction they are there
they become radicals and Hillary more
than her husband tried to push the
spirit
in that direction as well so now they're
going on this big stadium tour to do I
don't know to do a two-man show to do a
little vaudeville act probably a bad
idea though
during the me to age because do you
outlook I don't know if your history
buffs or not but Bill Clinton had a few
accusations thrown against him and they
were much more credible than Brett
Kavanaugh so Christiane Amanpour to her
credit she's a terrible journalist but
to her credit she asks Hillary Clinton
what about the allegations against your
husband here's what she has to say
prepared to have questions about that
moment in 1998 the impeachment the
allegations of sexual harassment against
your own husband are you prepared to
answer those questions is he prepared to
answer them and how do you see that
similar or different from what President
Trump is being accused of and Cavanagh
and others today well there's a very
significant difference and that is the
intense long-lasting partisan
investigation that was conducted in the
90s if you know the Republicans starting
with President Trump on down want a
comparison they should welcome such an
investigation themselves excuse me what
you were asked about the allegations you
were asked about the elegance she says
oh it's a the difference is that darn
monster ken starr that's the difference
the vast right-wing conspiracy so well
maybe you could talk about the
allegations first also if you want an
investigation Brett Kavanaugh just
testified more than all other Supreme
Court nominees combined and he he also
had a seventh FBI investigation of him
so even that doesn't make any sense but
just look at that she learns nothing
first of all she doesn't believe
anything that's why for her it always
just goes back to this investigation and
they wronged me and me me me me me but
she she was singing this exact same tune
in the 1990s here is Hillary Clinton
could have been yesterday though it was
actually 20 years ago talking to Matt
Lauer on The Today Show about the
allegations against her husband First
Lady Hillary Rodham Clinton candidly
answered questions with NBC's Matt Lauer
on The Today Show this morning
she wasted no time in slamming special
prosecutor Kenneth Starr accusing him of
being behind the allegations that have
rocked the presidency we get a
politically motivated prosecutor who is
allied with the right-wing opponents of
my husband who has literally spent four
years looking at every telephone a
million dollars it more than that now
but looking at every telephone call
we've made every check we've ever
written scratching for dirt intimidating
witnesses doing everything possible to
try to make some accusation against my
husband if he were to be asked today
mrs. Clinton do you think he would admit
that he again has caused pain in this
marriage no absolutely not
and he shouldn't the great story here
for anybody willing to find it and write
about it and explain it is this vast
right-wing conspiracy that has been
conspiring against my husband since the
day he announced for president that's
that's the story the vast right-wing
conspiracy that was her phrase by the
way I had to change the clip there at
the end talk about conspiracies when you
watch that first flip on YouTube the
audio cuts out when you get to the money
line when you get to the vast right-wing
conspiracy I don't know there might be a
vast left-wing conspiracy there but
that's what she said it's all about the
vast right-wing conspiracy forget the
allegations she was singing that same
tune then she doesn't learn anything she
doesn't learn that you can't call half
the country deplorable and irredeemable
she's still doing it two years later she
doesn't learn any of these things she's
unable to see the hypocrisy two of the
investigations you heard there you know
Matt Lauer chiming and Owen spends 30
million dollars all it's been so ah and
now I wonder what Hillary Clinton thinks
about the Muller investigation into
Trump I wonder what she thinks about
special counsels independent counsels
obviously it would have flipped and she
can't see the hypocrisy because of the
defining feature of the Clintons which
is shamelessness and pride hubris they
go hand in hand if you're very very
prideful you can't you can't see your
own flaws you and you can't feel any
shame so that the defining feature of
the Clintons they could look you in the
face and say I do not have sex with that
woman two seconds later yeah I think I
might have had sex with that woman but
listen you should still believe me
no shame at all and and that's what's
motivating this tour look it's gonna be
a stadium tour all of the questions are
gonna be highly vetted of course they're
not no one's gonna be able to get in
their face with a camera or anything
like that but even so they can't see
that in the me2 era in the era that was
made possible because Hillary Clinton
lost
they were finally Democrats were finally
able to talk about the sexual misconduct
it typifies by the Clinton
administration in the me2 era maybe it's
not a great idea Hillary for you and
Bill to be out there doing a little
soft-shoe on stage they can't see it
it's so much pride and it's so dishonest
and and speaking of conspiracies
speaking of the vast right-wing
conspiracy I will point out at least our
conspiracy is honest at least the vast
right-wing conspiracy not that not what
she's talking about
and not the left-wing conspiracy but the
actual right-wing conspiracy you know
that we're all a part of here welcome to
the conspiracy at least we're honest
about it were not pretending we're not
being sanctimonious cocaine Mitch was
really excellent about this he's turned
the the cough fa up to like pablo
escobar's levels here's cocaine Mitch
explaining why he's completely ready to
confirm a Supreme Court justice or
implying he's completely ready to
confirm a Supreme Court justice even in
the election year of 2020 if Donald
Trump were to name somebody in the final
year of his first term in 2020 are you
saying that you would go ahead with that
nomination well I understand your
question and what I told you was what
the what the history of the Senate has
been you have to go back to the 1880 to
find the last time a vacancy created in
a presidential election year on the
Supreme Court was confirmed by a Senate
of a different party than the
president's that's the hizzle in if you
can't answer my question are you saying
that well the answer to your question is
we'll see whether there's a vacancy in
2020 I love that answer so don't you
think it's a little hypocritical well
you know I just I'm just well do you
remember
in 1492 Christopher Columbus sailed the
ocean blue it's actually even less
deceptive than that because what he
would McConnell is saying is yeah this
that just that's not how it works
Trent and nobody knows how the Senate
works better than Mitch McConnell this
guy knows how the machinery of the
Senate works and he's saying yet and of
course in an election year when the
Senate is controlled by the party by a
different party than the White House of
course they're not going to confirm a
nominee why would that they haven't done
it since 1880 he's not saying he's not
coming up with some sanctimonious hubbub
he's not dragging out women and and you
know manipulating women who may or may
not have suffered any assaults and
putting them on TV and using them as
tearful human shields he's saying no
that's just the way politics works I'll
be very honest about it I love it and
but you know he doesn't quite answer the
question so then Chris Wallace says well
don't you think it's hypocrite or are
you gonna confirm somebody in 2020 and
Mitch McConnell as well oh just one
second Christie would excuse me for one
second Oh
and and he's exactly right
that's exactly the right answer chuck
Grassley is kind of playing games and
being a little deceptive but mitch is
being spot-on honest about it and
honestly political great I'll take that
any day the president Trump is honestly
political he's honestly political in
what he says and I think people like
that they you know some sanctimonious
people want to pretend that there's
something unpleasant about it I don't
think I find that much more pleasant
than Hillary Clinton smearing her
husband's victims and her husband's
accusers and then talking about vast
right-wing conspiracy
and being so sanctimonious quivering lip
on on Matt Lauer absolutely speaking of
why we fight I have got the great
Sebastian Gorka coming on the show today
he's got a wonderful book why we fight
defeating America's enemies with no
apologies he is it gives us a great
insight having worked in the White House
with the administration with that
further ado dr. Gork and we got a lot
more coming up after that
dr. Gorka thank you for being here my
pleasure Michael my pleasure you know I
mean you know I'm a big fan of yours I'm
a big fan of everything you write and
tweet and when you're on television
I really like the book why we fight and
in this moment this Cavanagh moment I'm
thinking not just of why we fight abroad
but why we fight at home as well this
was a brutal fight you you're an insider
you've been in the administration what
lessons do you think conservatives can
take away from this bloody Kavanagh
battle very very simply that the
Democrats have made their Faustian
bargain when they want power they will
do whatever it takes to get the power
they take a man I mean look this is not
an insult
I love the man he's a godly man but he's
actually a boring Boy Scout a
milquetoast decent guy then Brett
Kavanaugh and they're prepared to accuse
him of serial rape and attempted murder
it means they have no morals I mean it's
not immoral but it's a moral yes it's
it's a sociopathic level of greed for
power and and it also demonstrates that
they've never given up they lost the
election but they will grasp at anything
to maintain power and if that means
turning the Supreme Court into a
legislating radical body then that's
what they're going to do but I have to
say one thing I know he's my old boss
and we stay in touch what the president
did yesterday was epic to the hill with
terrific I mean just to the whole world
to say he is innocent in front of his
mother his wife his daughters it was the
right thing to do and it's pure Trump it
was it was total moral clarity as well
this is something I'm constantly
surprised by his people say Oh President
Trump he never has read a book he
doesn't go to church he doesn't I say
okay regardless of any conjecture you
might have he is able to identify clear
moral issues his tweet about Christopher
Columbus was excellent I mean even from
that even from these issues he really
does seem to cut through the fog
do we elect the President to give us a
pistol a logical discourse ontological
debate no we'll leave that to Drew
Clavin I mean seriously that's right and
I would like to know - speaking of
epistemological debate we're even
reading the tea leaves you know
ambassador nikki Haley has stepped down
at the UN everybody is rending their
garments gnashing their teeth I think
I'm the only person who like doesn't
really care that much you did a good job
and now she'll do something else we'll
get another guy in there the UN doesn't
matter as an insider what is your take
on this it's so funny so I'm in New York
because why we fight came out today and
doing back-to-back media I went on a
conservative radio show that was trying
to hypothesize is she the author of
anonymous is that one and I said on live
radio cigars take the tinfoil hat and
seriously
look look at the body language of the
president and Nikki in that oh this is
the Oval Office presser you don't get
prep I mean Rex Tillerson finds out from
a tweet that he's been can okay Nikki
gets the Oval Office presser the body
language is I respect you I like you you
like me you've been a great trooper I
got teenage kids I'm gonna take a break
now it's look sometimes I know you like
them a cigar is just a cigar right it's
a very good point it's a very good and
you know on the role of the UN which I
can't wait until that becomes the Donald
Trump residential condominiums in six
more years but before they knock it to
rubble
just tweet it to me they should turn
this is turning into a veteran's over VA
veteran so the nice would that be great
that would be so beautiful yeah our
veterans deserve waterfront front news
in Manhattan I think certainly more than
Iran and China and when you look around
at the geopolitical threats one thing
I've always loved about you is you speak
very bluntly you don't pull your punches
and then you you can back it all up and
I love it
the end of why we fight or the end of
why we fight you dedicate a chapter to
Whittaker Chambers and I think Young
Conservatives don't even know who
Whittaker Chambers is they've never read
witness why include chambers and what
what should conservatives remember from
our not so distant past so I put three
heroes in there who wore uniforms and
their Avena so the books about strategic
threats what bold Trump's going to do
about them and then stories about real
heroes and I thought to myself hang on
you don't have to wear a uniform or
carry a gun to be a hero and and
Whittaker Chambers is that man and and
and justice Kavanaugh is that man and
the really I mean I didn't plan this
because the book was went to the
printers before you know this ordeal he
went through but when a kid chambers
speaks to what we've just witnessed over
the last month because the Democrats
have done this before right 1948 this
man stood up for the truth he was
accused of being homosexual a drunk he
was accused of killing his brother all
of it were lies total and utter Democrat
lies why because the man he accused of
being a Soviet agent was a a darling of
the Democrat Party Alger Hiss Alger had
to be defended at all cost
we now have the proof because after
chambers died we have the Venona decrypt
that his was a Soviet agent but this was
1948 Michael so you know Whittaker
Chambers is important because he was
Cavanaugh before Cavanaugh was born and
it tells you everything you need to know
about the Democrats it's so true and
that history in particular is so
important I'm so glad you included
chambers in there because so much of
what happened to Richard Nixon comes out
of that moment because Nixon believed
chambers opposed hiss and I think that's
just been lost even to Young
Conservatives so I've got to let you go
I know you're doing a ton of media you
know right now back-to-back media what
should we take away now forgetting about
the inner personnel fights in the
administration looking at the United
Nations looking
at all of our geostrategic threats what
should we be paying attention to
especially as we go into the midterms
okay this isn't meant to be flipped
but the Donald will take care of all the
international stuff
I mean he'll just deal with it doesn't
matter Russia North Korea China China
he'll deal with it I mean the guy is
just his strategics intuitive sense is
spooky my one message is never give up
on him and never give up on on the
country he is taking the the brickbats
for us he heat stood up for Cavanaugh
because he's been through it he's walked
through the valley in the last two years
everything they've accused him of so the
president will never be a
neoconservative he's doing what he's
doing for love of country my one message
is really simple if you like what you've
seen in the last two years if you were
shocked by what the Democrats did to
Cavanaugh get out and vote and get
everybody you know who's gonna sit at
home to vote because the stakes it's not
an exaggeration exaggeration the stakes
are more important than anything else
you could do in your lifetime right now
and while you're going out to vote you
should also stop at a bookstore I
actually don't think bookstores exist
anymore but you know at least stop in
your car and order on Amazon or
something why we fight it's really
terrific it's great to read you should
read it before the midterms as you
getting your subscription to the other
Kingdom that's right very important you
have to well you're on your phone open
up two windows
subscribe another Kingdom coming out
this week and why we fight a wonderful
book good luck in the media blitz dr.
Gork always good to have you here and
then we'll have to have you back soon
god bless I love talking to that guy you
guys also just want his voice I want to
say if I can't do his voice unfortunate
work it up I'm I finally been able to do
my Mitch McConnell impression so maybe
I'll have to work at my doctor Gorka
voice still a lot more
get to before I do that before we talk
about Rand Paul's predictions that
someone's gonna be assassinated in this
insane hysterical leftist climate and
Kanye West prompting CNN to do a
minstrel show I've got a second byte of
Facebook and YouTube go to daily wire
calm why you getting me you get the
Indra Clevenger you get the bunch of
bureaus oh you test questions in the
mailbag none of that matters there there
are tears of rage that are coming across
this country tears of rage tears of rage
and if you don't have your fda-approved
leftist tears vessel you're gonna drown
take precautions now I can only do so
much I can only warn you I can't save
you if you won't help yourself go to
daily wire comm get the pumpkin spice
Cory Booker Spartacus spice leftist
dears tumblr and we'll be right back
Rand Paul is predicting that this insane
climb ginned up by the left by Democrats
I don't want there to be any confusion I
don't think there is any moral
equivalence
I don't think both sides are to blame I
think the left is to blame I think the
people who fund the left are to blame
like George Soros and others
I think the hysterical elected officials
of the Democratic Party like Maxine
Waters who calls for violence against
Republicans and Trump supporters I think
the leaders of the Democrat Party who
encourage people to chase down
Republicans in their restaurants and
public spaces in their homes for their
children's sleep I think they are to
blame they're the ones who are creating
this awful climate and Rand Paul is
suggesting that somebody might get hurt
or killed from this here is people need
to realize that when people like Cory
Booker's say get up in their face he may
think that that's okay but what he
doesn't realize is that for about every
thousand person that might want to get
up in your face one of them is going to
be unstable enough to commit violence
when I was at the ball field when Steve
Scalise was nearly killed the guy
shooting up the ball field and shooting
I think five or six people were shot
these gliese was almost killed he was
yelling this is for health care get a
list in his pocket of conservative
Republicans that he wanted to kill you
know when I was attacked in my yard and
had six of my ribs broke and pneumonia
lung contusion all of that these are
people that are unstable we don't want
to encourage them we have to somehow
ratchet it down and say we're not
encouraging that violence is ever OK
ever a reason for or a means for trying
to resolve things I feel that there's
going to be an assassination I really
worry that someone is going to be killed
and that those who are ratcheting up the
conversation those who are ratcheting up
saying get in their face they have to
realize that they bear some
responsibility of this elevates to
violence absolutely right 100% right and
it's not I think some people are hearing
what Rand Paul is saying they're saying
oh well that's hyperbolic rhetoric it's
not when it's coming from Rand Paul I
mean this guy talk
a bad place wrong place at the wrong
time this guy was at the Congressional
baseball shooting when that lefty tried
to shoot up the game he was at he was
just mowing his lawn when his neighbor
broke six of his ribs really put him
down for the count for a long time this
is not idle chatter the guy's been
attacked twice and his life has been
threatened both times and this is a this
is a real problem you know there there
have been assassinations in this country
presidents had been assassinated many
presidents have been assassinated have
been shot just in the 1960s people were
getting shot major political figures
were getting shot presidents were being
killed there's no reason to think that
this can't happen again you know we're
in this complacent moment because
everything is so easy and our culture is
so decadent and everything is so
convenient we don't ever have to even
leave our couches if we don't want to
things can go south real fast you know
everything stays pretty nice until it
all plummets south real fast and and
people are careless with their rhetoric
I'm not saying that you shouldn't be
strong that you shouldn't say exactly
what you think that you shouldn't be
perfectly blunt I think you should I'm
advocating that much more than
mealy-mouthed milquetoast echo not a
voice politics but you've got to know
what you're talking about you've got to
be precise in your language the left
wants to be imprecise in its language so
that it can encourage hysterical little
children to go out and shriek and scream
in the gallery of the Senate well Brett
Kavanaugh is being confirmed to the
court Wow Cavanaugh what have you to do
with us Brett of Maryland rah-rah know
nobody you shouldn't be doing that you
should be act like an adult I mean it is
a real immaturity
it's a it's a true immaturity hear that
word hasn't even really been used to
describe the left but that's what it is
it's an intellectual immaturity a
political immaturity and a spiritual
immature moral immaturity they don't
know that much they're not educated
meaning they haven't been brought up the
right way and they're not behaving like
adults and they really should because
children can be can do really reckless
things and I hope I hope it doesn't come
to that but Rand Paul might have a good
point
before we end here
my favorite story of the entire day CNN
do basing itself as as best at cam and I
know that that's a really high bar they
have a panel on on Don Lemon show and
here is look you know Kanye West has
stated his political views he likes the
president he likes him for a number of
reasons he as far as pop musicians and
actors and actresses go Kanye West is
one of the more thoughtful and
articulate of them
you know I mean when you listen to like
she was was the girl not a [ __ ] no not
Apatow I forget one of those girls
though she was gonna run for the Senate
I mean she's like screeching and
screaming nobody wants that I mean how
do you narrow it down to just one Kanye
West on the whole actually isn't they
probably the upper 50% of the pack here
is how CNN treats him what happens when
Negroes don't read and and we have this
now and now Donald Trump is going to use
it and pervert it and he's gonna have
somebody who can stand with him and take
pictures
[Laughter]
listen black folks are about to trade
Kanye West and the racial draft okay
they've had it with him and he's an
attention [ __ ] like the president he's
all of a sudden now the the model
spokesperson he's the token negro of the
of the Trump administration this is
ridiculous and no one should be taking
Kanye West seriously he's clearly has
issues he's already been hospitalized
this is what happens when Negroes don't
read books that's Don Lemon and then the
other people on the panel just going
right along with it oh yeah he's the
token negro he's the hehehe ha ha and
what this amounts to what CNN amounts to
is a is a modern-day minstrel show
that's what it is
that's that's what they're doing they
are because what does a minstrel show a
minstrel shows when you go on camera you
go on stage and you perform a caricature
of what your audience expects you to
look because of your race because of
your gender because if someone else's
raise someone else's gender and you play
that caricature and you do that
soft-shoe well that's what a Negro looks
like when he doesn't read books ha ha ha
teehee that's what that is it's really
it's really despicable because
so it so narrows what people are not
just as individuals not just within
their communities it narrows what whole
races are it shrinks them it makes them
shallow I had this experience I was in
New Orleans when I was moving out from
New York to Los Angeles and I stopped in
New Orleans and I got tricked by some
hustler on the street and the guy says
he comes up he actually comes up to my
buddy and he says hey man I'll bet you
ten dollars that I can tell you where
you got your shoes both city and state
so my buddy I think he bought his shoes
in Maine or something he said oh there's
no West an easy ten dollars okay yeah
okay fine I'll uh yeah you can tell me
where I got the issue of city and state
yeah I'll give you ten dollars
he said you got him in New Orleans
Louisiana said no I actually got him in
Maine he said no you got him on your
feet right now in New Orleans Louisiana
ha ha ha you know and my buddy had to
pay him ten bucks and so I was a funny
joke so later on were walking through
walking down Bourbon Street or something
and some guy turns to us and he does
this same stick he goes hey man I'll bet
you ten dollars that you can't tell me
where you got shoes New Orleans we try
blah blah and I cut him off I was like
yeah I know where I got my shoes I got
him in New Orleans Louisiana no money
and and then he drops the whole show he
said okay all right no worries and he
starts behaving like a normal person and
it was really jarring cuz the line is
pretty funny I'm probably gonna use the
line myself you know that I tell you
where you got your shoes but it was the
it was the performance of it that
because this guy you know he's hanging
out on the streets of New Orleans he
looks a certain way he's a certain age
he's in a certain place that he's got to
put on a show he's got a he's got a
kowtow to a certain line that we expect
him to to behave like and that's exactly
what CNN is demanding Kanye West that's
exactly what Democrats are demanding
that's exactly and it's not a race thing
either
Oh white white Democrats are demanding
this as well they're saying who was it
some actress tweeted out a picture and
said make Kanye Kanye again he's got to
stop being Republican he's got to start
he's got to stop being independently
minded he's got to start kowtow to the
line he black people are supposed to be
Democrats that's what we're telling you
you have to perform this way it's really
narrow it's really shallow and I'm
really pleased that no less a pop icon
a pop star that word is abused icon but
pop star
Kanye West is is the one who's breaking
out of that it was yeah it was Alyssa
Milano that's right was Alyssa Milano
who said make Kanye Kanye again he's got
to behave a certain way he's it he's
misbehaving do what we tell you to do
behave the way we tell you to behave and
CNN is doing the same thing it's a
minstrel show it's really really
despicable but that CNN isn't it we
don't have time for this day in history
because I got to go too bad we'll get to
it tomorrow make sure you get your
mailbag questions in we have a lot to
talk about this has been a whirlwind of
a week and it's only Wednesday so make
sure you get those in in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show I will see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018